Comedy Central has a show called tosh
point-o it's a show that does they play
a lot of viral online clips and
celebrity stuff and stereotypes and
popular culture it's been around for
about 10 years on Comedy Central it's a
lot of repurposed content and a clip of
the David Pakman show actually turned up
last night on what I think was their
season premiere episode they never
contacted me about using the clip
hilariously tosh point-o spur do sirs
actually contacted me a few years ago
about being on the show it never
happened and then yesterday a few
seconds of the show appear on their
latest episode check it out he begged
the person in the next room to learn
some English so I would at least know
what he's planning to bomb this morning
it's Noah's Twitter feed that has some
critics outraged with snarky tweets more
than a year old about quote fat chicks
and Jews Sean Hannity was caught
deleting a bunch of tweets related to
Michael Cohen the president's boyfriend
is in trouble
publicly posting on the Internet can
come back to haunt you Sean Hannity got
caught because some nerd invented the
screenshot bot which follows Twitter
accounts of people like Hannity and
immediately post a screenshot of any
tweet they try to secretly delete so
it's sort of funny I'm not even really
too sure what to say about it I don't
know how many people watch this show
only two people contacted me to say that
they saw me on there in comparison when
Joe Rogan mentioned me dozens of tweets
and emails about it but I think
generally speaking they do some clever
stuff on this show right Pat Amina maybe
you're more familiar with it than I am
I honestly didn't know it was still on
but I did watch it back in the day be
honest when you first heard that you
were featured on tosh point-o were you
nervous because I thought maybe you were
like the subject of criticism some
things be made fun of I was worried for
you
yeah actually so I didn't I don't know
enough about the show to know that that
is a possibility but then when I
mentioned this to a couple of people
they immediately reacted like oh no what
did they do to you but I was so ignorant
about the fact that people often do get
made fun of
that I didn't even know that that's
something I should have been afraid of
one funny note is the copyright
imbalance that exists for companies like
Comedy Central versus for shows like the
David Pakman show
so they used our clip they didn't ask
they're using it for profit I don't care
I really have no problem with it at all
I think in court they could say it's
really fair use because it was just part
of a broader story that we were telling
bla bla bla
I would never challenge their use of it
in any way it's great it's fine we now
in what you just listened to and watched
have used their clip of our clip on our
program and it is almost guaranteed that
when we upload this clip to YouTube
YouTube will say their algorithm would
identify or maybe even Comedy Central
would manually file claims saying hey
the david pakman show used our clip
without permission so we get the ad
revenue from the clip instead of the
david pakman show even though it's my
clip that they used without asking that
caused me to cover it but I feel like
that's just a battle we can't win Patt
there is just a significant intellectual
property imbalance that exists out there
and we're just the little guy and we've
got to live with it there is a good
chance that we're gonna upload this
video to YouTube later and it will get D
monetized or we'll even get a copyright
strike for it we'll be on the lookout
for it I don't know if we'll have any
recourse but it there is an imbalance
yeah my view is this is all fair use
right I mean we're doing a clip
commenting on tosh point-o use of our
video tosh point-o is doing a story
about something twitter related and
they're using a piece of our show it's
all fair use all of the creators should
get to monetize the the content that
they put together wouldn't it be nice if
that was the status quo but
unfortunately it's it's not